[Music]
in not my fault news it's almost an
andreas fault submitted by Astroworld we
got Travis Scott on this yeah
sickle mode yeah I don't know the only
reason why I know about that is because
I heard about the roller coaster what
happened to concerts that he does I was
so drunk and super we all dude I don't
know what the [ __ ] I'll get us all
boring perform at the house I'm watching
it I was drunk too
yeah we were drunk or is this fangame
I'm so glad don't think it songs about
Jane and not the other L I was like all
the Patriots are gonna [ __ ] win give
me another shot person's fault um a
teacher says she was wrongfully fired
over a topless selfie that was leaked to
students that isn't her fault I want to
know the story she should get a
certificate of most popular teacher of
the semester yep most viewed so this 25
year old former middle school math
teacher named Lauren hmm I sorta
sounding like a porno from Long Island
oh yeah it's a porno she was recently
fired because two years ago she sent it
topless photo to her then-boyfriend who
was also a teacher in the same district
and somehow a student got ahold of it
and started spreading around so is it
the boyfriend in the students fault yes
what the [ __ ] gotta pay the pay the
crime Wow exactly crazy that's [ __ ] up
so now she's suing the school district
for 3 million dollars you know what when
these stupid rules happen I want to know
who made those decisions because I
immediately superintendent that was a
male a female male okay he was [ __ ]
drooling on that [ __ ] and his wife was
like what the [ __ ] are you doing exactly
what this is this is this is
preposterous
well no I got a I got a [ __ ] slam the
hammer down on this [ __ ] and then like
he's blaming the teacher huh you just
wanted to shame her but the stupid thing
is I don't know like wouldn't you
immediately go to the boy for
because he let that [ __ ] leak so did the
boyfriend a fire cuz he's a teacher - we
don't know anything about what happened
to the boyfriend
or the students who's possessed it yeah
do we know do we have the photo yes we
do there is an uncensored version of it
but I'm gonna show you I need to see for
purposes I need to see this photo here
you go thank you
she looks like a student yes so she was
like why is she [ __ ] me oh my god her
room is all dirty - no show you know it
was a private folk exactly it was
private
so she this is wild so you topless
pictures I'm dude I know but damn dude
is like she always begs for it I'm like
no it could get hacked and leak
somewhere I never ever ever do it I send
a lot of buff photos though she sends a
lot of butt photos my whole phone if you
ever got my phone congratulations
there's already photo shoots out there
with my but now hack into your phone
thanks shouldn't but I will say none of
it's nude so it's waste your time that's
the same some granny panties you up
gonna do it that's my favorite kind
though if you want to hack into my phone
got a lot of dick my dick that's tighter
I want you to [ __ ] see it [ __ ]
go ahead hack it to my [ __ ] you're gonna
get calmed on by my video your dick in
different locations uh-huh the bathroom
the living room at night in the Sun I
said it a Jess and she liked please stop
to be a joke she asked for them does she
legit ask you for dick photos yeah and
if there's even one why bus it inside of
the sink so I hope you hack us find that
one [ __ ] of him ruining my sink
yeah you said that's a dress up yeah I
love that [ __ ] you see the little
bubbles
so funny because like I had this counter
and the bathroom wheels here right so
then like I was blessed him and it all
like oh [ __ ] I gotta come somewhere and
I had to [ __ ] Michael Jackson
tippy-toe to [ __ ] lift hey motoki
that's what I call backsplash you have
to imagine me the magic quesadilla
what are you guys talk about sexy [ __ ] I
just imagine Jess so it's like okay it's
cool mm-hmm
that's how you like wash your mind of
disgusting thoughts yeah because I'll
[ __ ] vomit if I picture any of you
guys make it yeah not good as your ugly
or anything like that but family it's
incestual yeah you're a gross sister
that smells like [ __ ] that's with a and
I picture you as like a four year old
child with snot coming down your [ __ ]
nose mm-hmm and then you're like and I'm
like yeah you're nice anyway so now she
is suing the school district because
she's saying that it was gender
discrimination because she's the only
one I got fired or like no there were no
other repercussions yeah she's the
victim in the end she's responsible for
her own picture no no no that's like
saying my private stuff but my computer
is well what I'm trying to say is that
out for this [ __ ] no no what I'm trying
to say is that lame when you're the guy
who's like cracking the case right if
I'm not superintendent yes I'm not gonna
go to everyone else and find all his
evidence and find out the [ __ ] case
I'm going to this person to say look
figure this [ __ ] out so that she should
never be able to take a picture on her
personal cause she can but she can't but
I'm sorry I got leaked but what do you
want me let me do code for an and is
saying how dare she take this private
photo of herself no no that's not what
I'm saying I don't think you're
explaining yourself right because
because no matter what let's say in a
case where she took a she took a picture
of her boob or whatever she did because
maybe she was getting a surgery or
something right and engineer to send it
to her doctor or whatever
right let's say that lead it's not her
fault because she's doing something
medical not sexual yeah thank you was so
pure like she was just getting their
baby I mean that doesn't even matter the
point is once it leaves your phone or
even if you got hacked and it got taken
without you know that intended purpose
right it's not her fault right yes it's
the person who leaked it to children
it's that the superintendent's
responsibility to go to the guy who
leaked it yes yes why because he's a
teacher well it's not in his school
though it's district just so happens the
porn picture isn't another teacher weeks
weights up yeah I guess a superintendent
win Kim Kardashian's sex tape leaked
that's Kim Kardashian's fault that's
what I'm saying well that was probably a
pay-for that the only way she could get
in trouble is if she sent those pictures
to children exactly that's the only way
she could get in trouble you never did
right and then so the superintendent
said that he pitied her and he said how
can they put you in front of a classroom
full of boys where they can pull out
their phones and look at this image of
you well they don't even need to because
25 year old teacher that looks something
like hot like that that's going home
jacking off thinking about her already
no doubt about it so then she was like
what what is there to feel sorry for
that I'm a woman like all the guys
teachers I walk around shirtless because
they're by the poor winner of the [ __ ]
like they don't get any of are we sure
that the superintendent said that or was
it my good friend ant here what I'm
saying is she just needs to take
responsibility of what came out like it
what so what I mean is that if you were
okay no I don't think she's got fire she
needs to take responsibility for having
taken a nude photo of herself I'm trying
to explain it so let's say Nikki was
telling Steve this is why I don't take
pictures for you topless is she's
thinking responsibility' because she
knows the repercussions right
but that's my choice that I don't want
it to ever everyone ever have so I've
also ever sent on a picture I would know
that it could get the hands of someone
else right but you shouldn't get fired
for that I don't think so
but but you won't you shouldn't be relic
consequence but you shouldn't be held
even responsible like suspension no
there should not be any job recover
percussions the consequence of you
already is that you're the victim and
people often you should [ __ ] Christina
next to a window because somebody could
walk by and see that [ __ ] and film you
and then they could leak that [ __ ] and
then it's your fault for [ __ ]
crushing the next to a window bro our
windows in the back of the house if you
have the windows open you could get I
heard something about like you could be
as sexual what is it the predator not
predator so I don't think it's the word
that you're looking for is
responsibility it's like more like
common sense that there is risk involved
any time you send a new body right but
it shouldn't be the risk is you could
lose your job and for taking the photo
it is not your fault right so that's why
I take responsibility isn't the right
word to use its she should have the
common sense to understand that there is
risk involved with her actions that's
not her fault it's not her fault it is
not her fault right but to be aware it's
like this it's like let's say if I'm
going through a dangerous neighborhood
right and I get robbed people will be
like what you knew it was a dangerous
neighborhood you should take
responsibility for that but
responsibility is not the right word for
that it's it's still oh well you know
it's the robbers fault not my fault for
walking this is more like general
callousness drives me crazy like I'll
see like some news article about how a
couple got killed over vacation walking
next to a waterfall and all the comments
like who's dumb [ __ ] you've never been
walking bought waterfall they deserve
this [ __ ] and I'm like man you guys are
fun victim-blaming yeah all the time
Lacoste and you don't know what what
victim-blaming is kind of fun some
people know you shouldn't have your face
in it like obviously it's not her fault
but I will say like try to be conscious
of
Toki's going down - yeah you guys are
totally right we got a body count no guy
has ever gotten a topless photo on my
body and never will not even if you're
married to me you'll never get one it'll
never happen I want one cuz there not
only do it do it is my picture all over
the internet but also I get blame for it
you're not by me I'm free the titty free
the nipple I'm against I'm not I'm
against her getting in trouble for it
because they're like whenever these
rules happen right they further they
stop progression and sexual expression
because I like it I want more of it
right so but the more you blame the
women they hide they shy from a deep
they go back into the turtle shell yeah
but then if they were more bold about it
and it's like you could have a lot more
fun in the relationship because they're
not to worry but what more could
perpetuate the stigma of nude photos
being shameful than what the
superintendent just [ __ ] did and then
and then like half of the conversation
here other guy doesn't get lose his job
the other guy the teacher that wanted it
that got the picture yeah dude [ __ ]
me exactly don't I'm saying work it
becomes where anyone could even say it's
even slightly someone's fault
that's crazy and what about all the
students circulating nude photos
underage right and why are they
circulated cuz they like it so we live
in a repressed society where everyone
pretends they don't like something but
then pornhub is the most number one
[ __ ] visited website right that's what
is such a joke about our society
everyone pretends to be so much better
than [ __ ] while they jerk off at home
it's because they look at me like I'm
the bad guy when I'm open about
everything there was so Shamy I wonder
if it would still be the number one side
yeah no I agree with you that's what I'm
saying it's like you know how you're not
allowed to drink and then after 21 you
go [ __ ] crazy
yeah you just during the Prohibition how
people still get it got worse yeah
you can't touch true it's like if I saw
a lot of titties like we did in Vegas
back to back tub man I'm just like I
don't want to see a titty put a shirt on
lady but we live in a press society
where you see your friend's mom bent
over doggy style and your [ __ ] 11 and
you're like ah I don't even know what to
do with it that's [ __ ] welcome to
America
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]